[Music]
finally a Disney Channel movie based on
a property I'm somewhat familiar with
Kim Possible a sitch in time now let's
just around the age where I wasn't
really watching kids cartoons that much
I was around late high school early
college well when I saw people like John
DiMaggio Nicole Sullivan and Ricardo
Montalban were attached they said maybe
I should check this out
and of the few can possible shows I saw
I found myself actually enjoying it but
then again that was a long time ago
is it possible years later now that I'm
older I find that Kim Possible isn't as
funny as I remember it well I'm glad to
say no it's not only funny it's even
funnier this is an incredibly funny
character driven energized and just
downright fun film Kim Possible voiced
by christy carlson romano yeah she did a
lot for the Disney Channel didn't she
he's bummed out because her psychic and
dude in distress Ron stoppable Chucky
and I love these names he's moving to
Norway he still insists that he can show
up to help with the missions but being
so far away he's constantly showing up
late that of course doesn't help when a
good chunk of Kim Possible's worst
villains band together and say hey we're
gonna take over the world with time
travel they use this ancient monkey
statue that has magic to travel through
time and yeah that's kind of it I'll be
very honest this is not a very story
based movie it's pretty much just the
idea that the bad guys from this show
can travel through time the heroes can
follow and just all the strange and
weird things that come from it they try
to go back to Kim Possible and
kindergarten where they just make fun of
her they then go to her high school
where they try to make fun of her some
more one of the villains steals it for
her own and decides to use it to her own
advantage
all while Ron's naked mole-rat with the
voice of Michael Dorn comes from the
future to warn them of the dangers yeah
it's pretty crazy it's made very obvious
early on that the focus of this movie is
not gonna be telling an emotional or
gripping story it's just having an
excuse to put a bunch of funny scenes
and jokes together but thankfully all
those funny scenes and jokes are driven
entirely by the characters who are all
hilarious resulting in a lot of legit
laugh-out-loud moments watching these
Disney Channel movies I can probably
count on one
and how many times I actually verbally
laughed out loud with this one though it
entered the double digits this is funny
writing done by funny actors some random
actors in fact Michael Clarke Duncan is
in this Kelly Ripa Dakota Fanning vivica
a fox the list of oddness goes on but
they're all great and they know how to
make this already funny writing be even
funnier this is the kind of comedy that
makes me laugh the most the satire of
superhero secret agent stuff but also
while making fun of the flaws throwing
in some reality but also throwing in
some sir reality that makes it just so
crazy and zany I could listen to the
villains in this movie bicker forever
I love the alliance of convenience I
love that they all legitimately don't
get along but they have to in order for
their evil plans to work and even then
they're always trying to backstab one
another just listen to them argue about
putting the monkey statue in its place
it's hilarious people be true how come
now how can flimsy paper possibly beat
the raw density of stone the action is
also a lot of fun there's something
about the way it's animated that's
really energized and you kind of feel
every punch every swaying every dodge
it's kind of like the dialogue where
everything is just so quick and so fast
you almost don't have time to catch up
to it and because of that they try a lot
of various jokes some work some don't
but the ones that don't work are quickly
forgotten and replaced by the ones that
do work it's just so fast and well
edited it doesn't give you a time to
remember when there was a bad joke now
almost the people watching this are
probably aware of the show some might be
asking do I have to be aware of the show
or know anything about it in order to
watch the movie for the most part no it
helps if you know but you can quickly
catch on to what it's about
the characters are so well defined and
so funny that you ease up to them very
quickly and like I said the movie is not
really focused on any kind of drama or
story driven turmoil which I guess in
some respects could be a turn-off to
some people this is kind of like Big
Trouble in Little China or Evil Dead 2
or even the lego movie it just kind of
exists to have a bunch of jokes that
move really fast are thrown at you super
fast and when you're done you're left
with a lot of really funny moments and a
lot of really funny characters but
not really a heavyweight - anything
that's happened it just kind of goes
from one crazy thing to another crazy
thing if you're on board for the ride it
could be a lot of fun if I absolutely
had to nitpick I say maybe Kim Possible
is a little bit of a blank slate she
doesn't really have a ton of character
but it's kind of like Superman that's
not exactly the point
kids are supposed to imagine themselves
in the role going on these adventures
and fighting these bad guys and she does
it grade has all the one-liners and is
popular while doing it
Ron stoppable at times can have a voice
that's a little grating but mostly his
jokes it bull's-eyes let's be honest
though what this movie clearly likes as
well as the show I'm assuming are the
villains they're weird but funny they're
powerful but they're losers they're in
control but they're always bickering
they steal the show
whenever they're on screen so yeah even
if you're a fan of the show or I've
never even heard of it I'd still
recommend this movie if you haven't seen
the show it might take a little getting
used to what's going on but you'll catch
on real quick it's nothing great like I
said the story isn't really that much to
write home about but it's just fun it's
a fun fun film I found out recently the
same people that did the buzz lightyear
show and movie and you know what that
was really funny too I actually really
want to look into these shows I don't
know they're on DVD or if I have to
watch them another way but I say it's
worth it I say there's a lot of talented
people behind this they're creative
they're humorous they have memorable
characters this is certainly a mission
yet definitely want to accept
[Music]